las protestas en portland tuvieron un
desenlace fatal la ciudad ahora está
acostumbrada a las manifestaciones
diarias desde la muerte de georg floyd a
manos de un oficial de policía blanco el
sábado por la noche se presentaron
enfrentamientos entre los partidarios de
donald trump y activistas del movimiento
black light matter los hechos de
violencia desencadenará un juego de
culpas y señalamientos entre el
presidente y los demócratas son se
refirió al alcalde de portland set
wheeler y lo etiquetó de débil y
patético pero wheeler se defendió y se
pregunta seriamente señor presidente
porque es la primera vez en décadas que
eeuu ha visto este nivel de violencia
es usted quien ha creado el odio y la
división
su campaña de miedo es tan
antidemocrática como cualquier cosa que
ha hecho para crear odio y hostilidad en
nuestro hermoso país en el piropo
country se dice que el hombre muerto en
los enfrentamientos del sábado era un
miembro de paige trier un grupo de
extrema derecha con sede en portland
trump rindió homenaje a la víctima y una
concentración de partidarios del
presidente recorrió la ciudad el
mandatario usó twitter para alabar a sus
simpatizantes y dándolos de grandes
patriotas y es que una ola de nuevas
manifestaciones de black light matter
han sido provocadas por los disparos de
un oficial de policía blanco de los que
fue víctima de jake blake en kenosha
wisconsin se espera que el presidente
visite la ciudad del martes para
reunirse una fuerzas del orden pero
algunos temen que su visita sólo sirva
para aumentar las sanciones en el país